(jazzy music)
(train running)
- [Philip] The idea came from my father.
He told me that there
are pictures on the walls
and the subway stations of
old buildings, you know, old New York.
(train running)
20 years later, after
going through everything,
school, college and all that stuff,
I thought I would finally give it a look
and to see what my
father was talking about.
It was gonna be a short article.
I was going to illustrate some stations
with some pictures and tell the stories.
(laughs)
But it kinda ran away with me.
(subway running)
What I set out to do is make a record
of the appearance of the subway
stations in New York City.
I take drawings of the
mosaic or faience designs
on the walls which embellish the stations.
(atmospheric music)
I devote as much of my
time as I can to doing it.
Evenings, weekends, vacation time even,
you know, it's sort of
a consuming project.
(upbeat music)
So far, I've completed four volumes,
volume one, two, three and four.
My ambition is to take
care of all the lines
until all 496 or 469,
470 stations have been recorded and seen.
Why am I doing it?
(laughs)
Okay, my purpose in doing
this study is to make
a record of what we've got.
I wanted to like,
document when it was done
and who did it.
So that's what I wanted to do.
That's my focus, is to
give credit to those
who made it possible.
(subway announcement)
I really started in earnest in 1978.
And I thought I'd get this
project finished and wrapped up
by the year 2030, which
is only 14 years from now.
Perhaps I have to
re-estimate and, uh, suggest maybe
closer to 2040.
I'll be in my nineties then.
I hope I can still see.
(laughs)
The pleasure of doing the job is, um, payment.
I've committed to it, that's all.
It's my purpose.
It's my life.
It's become my identity.
So I have to live up to it.
(train running)